so I like to think you all had a part in
making the woman that she is such a
special lady Susan thanks again for your
blessed introduction and speaking of
cyclones the last few years have been
quite a whirlwind going from Congress to
be the director of America's Central
Intelligence Agency to now being
America's most senior diplomat as the
70th secretary of state of the United
States and if you believe the media I'm
supposed to be running for the Senate
down in Kansas right now but I love what
I'm doing working for President Trump to
deliver American foreign policy all
around but it wasn't so long ago that
Susan and I were just like so many of
you all we were raising our son we were
trying to build up our community we're
staying involved in our church I was
teaching Sunday school I ran a small
company of a couple hundred folks in
Kansas that job in Sunday school of
course was the best preparation to be
America's most senior diplomat I will
not elaborate and look I know - I know
American families are busy the first
thing on their minds isn't the work of
the State Department every day but it
matters it matters what we do that's why
I wanted to be here to talk with you all
about that today we have a
responsibility to keep you all safe we
advocate - for American businesses
abroad and help create jobs in every
state in the Union and we represent your
principles and I think our
administration does that remarkably well
and because people don't always know we
do I've made it one of my missions to
travel all over America to highlight the
great work that we're doing and I
couldn't be prouder of that work we've
we've executed a foreign policy that
American families in Des Moines and
Dubuque and in Davenport can can believe
in it's a pro national security foreign
policy focused on America it's a pro
religious freedom foreign policy and
it's a 100% pro-life foreign policy
[Applause]
Susan talked about this but my my faith
helps guide how I execute the mission
every day and I want to talk about that
just a bit how we execute this mission
let's start with the first point the
America's national security our foremost
objective by far it's the highest
priority of any secretary of state and
certainly for President Trump as well
our founders understood this they
understood the keeping our citizens safe
was the very first duty of any
government I wish some mayors to cross
America knew that too I think too about
my responsibilities in light of the
biblical call to be a good steward of
whatever you have
first Corinthians 4 says that those who
have been given a trust must prove
faithful and God's entrusted this
position to me for this time and I feel
every day the duty to honor that calling
look I've learned a lot about
stewardship too when I was in an m1 tank
you actually learned a lot inside an m1
tank it was my first assignment I was a
young second lieutenant leading a unit
that was then patrolling the East West
German border during the Cold War
freedom on one side communism on the
other that was a big responsibility for
me I had a little younger look to me at
that time and today for my job is a
little bit bigger but nonetheless the
threats we face today
aren't terribly different but they come
from different places today China is
working to take down freedom all across
the world today Russians want to poison
our democracy our institutions and used
information to sow discord here in
America
Iranians desire to spread the Islamic
Revolution all over the Middle East I
could go on but I'm doing all I can and
president Trump is doing all he can to
faithfully discharge our duties I work
pretty late most nights and I my staff
can attest to that I haven't gotten home
to see friends and family in Kansas a
whole heck of a lot and I've been
traveling all across the world I don't
get as much sleep as my doctor tells me
I should indeed I understand Michael and
L may be here maybe one of those pillows
might prove useful
the truth is president Trump has given
me the capacity and the drive to execute
diplomacy with a real level of
excellence not just because Americans
are depending on our success and our
ability get it right but striving for
excellence too because the call to
stewardship god has placed on us we can
feel in every circumstances just as he's
called all of us to do that wherever it
is we find ourselves stewarding my
position well also means making
decisions based on the truth our God has
indeed a God of truth and we should
every day seek to reflect his character
in that regard our administration has
told some very plain truth truths that
weren't recognized or worse had been
conveniently ignored for too long and
that perhaps starts with the Chinese
Communist Party no administration has
broken glass on the threat of our times
like we have for a long time foreign
policy thinkers truly the elites on the
East Coast for a long time foreign
policy thinkers thought that the more we
traded with China the more free that
nation would become in the last risk
there would be to the American people
but that's not what's happening today
today the Chinese Communist Party is
crushing freedom in Hong Kong it's
threatening a free Taiwan it's trying to
dominate world communications networks
including those right here in places
like Iowa and inside China just to give
a single example
a few weeks back I read a report about
the Chinese Communist Party forcing mass
abortions and sterilization on Chinese
Muslims in western China these are some
of the most gross human rights
violations we have seen and I've
referred to it as the stain of the
century but we've used the truth of
calling that out in a way to put it into
action we know these things are deeply
wrong and we know puts risk on people
all across America so we won't stay
still while Communist China tries to
crush the world's freedoms we've slapped
sanctions and travel restrictions on CCP
officials we're telling the truth every
day of where the coronavirus came from
and the Communists cover-up of that
virus we're revising Hong Kong's
agreements with Hong Kong as the
Communist Party erodes the freedom for
people in that place
we're fighting to to stop China from
stealing our intellectual property you
all work hard you create value we want
to bring fairness to to our trade
policies as we've done in the phase one
trade deal you should note the Chinese
Communist Party isn't too happy about it
a few weeks ago the Chinese state TV
called me quote the common enemy of
mankind end of quote
that's the people I knew pretty well
back in Kansas say well look it's I'm
guessing that because President Trump
and I are serious about this that will
face more of that from them but we'll do
the right thing for the American people
look we've also fundamentally changed
the way America treats the Islamic
Republic of Iran we know the fact the
nuclear deal gave the regime more money
to carry out terrorism presenting risk
to the United States and others in the
Middle East
outlaw regimes like the one that was led
by the Ayatollah only respond to
strength not to appeasement so we
flipped what the previous administration
was doing we ditched the deal and
implemented a brand new Iran policy this
policy deprives the regime of blood
money it denies the regime diplomatic
sanctuary and it deters the regime from
aggression and they felt that the regime
is felt the effects of the first two
steps and the terrorist Qasem Soleimani
has come to understand too that our
commitment to deterrence when we wiped
him off the face of the earth is real
that work is also important for the sake
of our closest friend in the Middle East
Israel here - my faith shapes my work
our nation's share judeo-christian
Christian roots our approach to
government draws on that beautiful
teaching from the first chapter of
Genesis that all human beings are made
in the image of God it's a major reason
why both countries have a high respect
for human dignity and personal liberty
each of our two nations respects human
rights and it only makes sense for the
two countries to be so close as close as
we possibly can be
and from a pure pure and foreign policy
standpoint Israel as an essential
security partner it's a model it's a
model in the Middle East of how to
create a thriving economy in Israel - is
a bastion of freedom in the region I'm
proud that there's not been any
administration that has supported Israel
in the way the president Trump and our
administration has done each of the
actions we've taken have been criticised
there's a reason they weren't done
before we moved our embassy to Jerusalem
we said that the Golan Heights is a part
of Israel
we've now unveiled a vision for peace
that recognizes reality on the ground
the biblical truths in that special
place and we've said that any scientism
is indeed any Semitism period I'm also
really proud of the work that we've done
defending religious freedom our first
freedom according to the Constitution
Thomas Jefferson was our first Secretary
of State he's got a nice statue in
Washington that I pray never comes down
I actually went there when some of the
riots were taking place in Washington DC
I walked up there early one morning and
on the walls of his monument as a quote
from the Virginia statute of religious
freedom which he helped author it says
quote Almighty God has created the mind
free no man shall be compelled to
frequent or support any religious
worship or ministry or shall otherwise
suffer on account of his religious
opinions or belief and now some 250
years later a high respect for this an a
that were right guides our
administration right now four out of
five people around the world don't enjoy
full religious freedom and we're
fighting tooth and nail to change that
we instituted new religious freedom
training programs for thousands of our
foreign service officers we've called
out China's war on faith it's masked
attention of wiggers it's godless
decisions to replace Church displays of
the ten commandments with words from
general secretary she have not gone
without being called out and now two
years running we at the State Department
have hosted
what we call the ministerial to advance
religious freedom nations and religious
leaders from all over the world coming
together to protect this essential
freedom would you believe our gathering
last year was the largest human rights
conference ever held at the State
Department this
this is different than the state
department of old this was such a big
deal because we recognize how much
previously untapped enthusiasm there is
all across the world to defend religious
freedom we're there to lead and if
you're here if you're here today and you
think you're part of a silent majority
in this issue take heart there are
plenty of folks all around the world who
aren't silent who are prepared to fight
for this freedom alongside of us and of
course one of them is President Trump
last year my friend and your Sam
Brownback who heads up these issues at
the State Department brought persecuted
religious minorities into the Oval
Office they met with the president
people of different faiths from places
like Sudan and Burma and Cuba the event
scheduled for just a few minutes and
there was a program in place I think we
all know by now president drugs trumped
us things his own way he spent almost
half an hour asking them very personal
questions hearing stories of burned
homes and of imprisoned family members
and reforming the American commitment to
religious freedom this administration
appreciates and knows that our rights
come from God not government can they
get an amen to that
[Applause]
and this brings me to my last point the
final thing that I want to share with
you today our ability to defend these
rights abroad must begin with our own
powerful example here at home America
sets the tone for the rest of the world
in this respect and our administration
has defended the rights of unborn like
no other administration in history
[Applause]
abortion quite simply isn't a human
right it takes a human life you all you
all know this
the psalmist says in Psalm 139 you knit
me together in my mother's womb this is
when life begins . so we've reinstated
the Mexico City policy so not a single
dime of American taxpayer money will
ever go to a foreign NGO that performs
active abortions anywhere in the world
and in the fall of last year and the
fall of last year secretary a czar at
Health and Human Services and I we
mobilized 20 countries to deliver a
joint statement at the UN criticizing
pro-abortion language in UN documents
this has not happened before we said
clearly quote that there is no
international right to an abortion it
may seem simple to you but in many parts
of the world this kind of language is
verboten and President Trump and our
team made a consistent effort in a push
to have this be recognized all across
the world
[Applause]
you know it's the joy and the small
things we sometimes find after we
released that statement one of our
colleagues received an email from a
friend in the pro-life movement in
Africa the note said quote never did I
think that America would use its great
power to speak for the protection of the
unborn in the most unambiguous and
unapologetic terms end of quote and
while it is sad that it took so long for
America to find her voice so powerfully
we have now done so and we appreciate
all of you who support our efforts every
single day I'll close with this thought
provoking question why is it that
America is unrivaled in our commitment
to freedom I think I know an answer
our founders built our country on a
commitment to essential rights uh nail
right something I spoke about at length
yesterday in Philadelphia they come from
these amazing documents our Declaration
of Independence and our Constitution and
a nation's foreign policy must be
grounded in those central understanding
that's the commitment that's made us a
shining star of Liberty in the world
it's a dark place somewhere in this
fallen world but our house our house of
foreign policy is built on solid rock on
these bedrock principles that were made
at our founding as Secretary of State
upholding this legacy is a enormous
privilege it is no easy task but I'm
leaning on my faith each and every day
to help me try to get it right your
prayers and I get wonderful notes from
all across America people who are
praying for me in their circles and
their groups and their Bible studies
your prayers helps sustain me
they help sustain me as I traveled as I
represent the greatest nation on earth
and by God's grace I'll continue to do
this each and every day may the Lord
bless you may God bless Iowa and may God
bless this great nation the United
States of America
thank you all
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen a great leadership
sight
I asked Secretary of State populists a
stain I asked Secretary of State Pompeo
if it'd be okay if I prayed for him as
we dismiss as well everybody all came to
that all right skip race a gun dealer
would just come to you this afternoon
our so thankful for a great day a day
that you have made a day that you've
orchestrated thank you for all the
messages that were delivered here today
lord I pray that we embrace them that we
take them to heart that we choose to be
a great generation in our time lord I
thank you for leaders the scripture says
you raise up leaders I thank you for
raising up Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo I pray that you'd have your hand
a favor blessing and protection all over
him give him wisdom unmeasured and Lord
I just prayed that this country under
president Trump's leadership
vice-president Pence's leadership
secretary state Pompeo leadership the
entire administration Lord would
continue to be that shining city on a
hill that beacon in the night that
points others to the one true hope and
that is you and Jesus saying we pray we
give you all the praise and the glory
amen and amen amen
thank you
[Applause]
see you next year